so for the first time ever!
after 50 seasons, after a hundred years of broadcast, you laugh you lose is
Changing the game. We're turning it upside down
Baby, it's no longer you laugh, You lose. It's get this- you laugh. You WIN!
*Epic Gamer Explosion.MP4*
No more  G-fuel required but it is a nice beverage regardless.
10% off
aaAGH
Teacher: what sound does the cow make?
Special ed kids: 3:22
MOOOMOOOOMOOMOOOMOOOOOOOOOOORGHHHAAAAAAAA
MOOOOMOOOOMOO-
I win!
>cutefelixkratta.mp3
I love how there's no context to this whatsoever
*Unholy roid rage ensues*
I don't I don't watch Tyler, but I only see him in the context of this; so he just seems like he's crazy
This is great. I have a great perception of this streamer
>felixskratta.mp3
x5
This clip is literally everywhere. I don't know why- I mean it's impressive but this is
Is this really enough for you kids to find a meme. To repost.
*tetris theme slowly spirals your soul into madness*
Now the real question is the tetris soundtrack copyrighted or not? *hmm*
ArE yA ReAdY kIdS?
9 yo kids : (In the distance) AYE AYE, CAPTAIN!
(Inaudible screeching) I CAN'T HEAR YOOOOOOOOOOOU!!!!!!!!
9 yo kids : (Louder) AYE AYE, CAPTAIN!!!
(OOHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH)
That's kind of sweet , that's not a really a laugh
That's just wholesome
when you leave the shop, but realize you left your son.
Oh no
ma
onomah (Oh no mah)
son
*felix contemplates life and why it has come to this...on youtube's favorite show...why??*
*okie life crisis over now we're good*
This is "YLYW" *skratta* I can laugh at that! I don't know if I want to though...
I feel uncomfortable...
ueh, yeah, beatboxer boi.
STOP it, wuehh-I don't care about West Coast Boi!
(intercom) We'll be closing in 2 minutes
*Sad Peter*
*Japanese weeb sh*t)
(Guy gets hit with what looks to me like a biscuit)
(Oh, look, Pewds just won!)
I love instinct(TEAM INSTINCT FTW!!!)
(Pewds drinkin' down that Gfuel)
(…)what fu*k that joke was
*METALLIC CLONK*
(slaughtering the ANIME GIRL with a frying pan!)
jEsUS cHRisT
Jacksepticeye, st0p killing the anime th0t, please...
*Success*
jesus..cryyy
What did she do?
This is disrespectful as Hell
learn to trick
Wow
>felixskratta.mp3
x5
(lady with accent: He's the world's champion in basketball freestyle!)
Oh god
You know only real show offs prac-, I mean it's impressive don't get me wrong-
But you know only show-offs really practice this kind of stuff
He's the world champion!
Daaaaaaaaaaaamn
That's naayysty
*Pewds laughs at the basketball trick hustler* haha look at the dood
WoRlD cHaMpIOn
Spectator: "Keep going, keep going, keep going"
Keep going... Jesus Christ, he's already dead...
(Roger Taylor trying to sing Numa-Numa up in here)
This is from the Swedish version of Idol.
I think at least...
I remember seeing this
(Dear lord, why did I have to get dragged into this?)
(I'm just your friendly neighborhood caption author)
(Good god, is he done yet?)
No... You know, I thought changing the name to you "YLYW" would actually benefit, but uh, it just seems like...
The clips are sh*t and I haven't even been trying all along...
Oh, it's a gun!
OH OF COURSE it's Russia... Jesus Christ...
Oh my God
Please tell me that's water, because that is the cutest...
That's the cutest thing I've seen in my life!
So then someone throws a match
*Pewds.exe has stopped working*
Sorry, I know that was a bit...
what is this hit or miss what the heck is this, huh? (Soft banjo plucking in backround)
What is happening???  (Soft banjo plucking in backround cont.)
*Guy running frantically*  (Soft banjo plucking in backround cont.)
Oh god, is he gonna get hit?  (Soft banjo plucking in backround cont.)
(Record scratch) Oh my god... (Rock music starts)
This gotta be fake...
Oh God, ohooho Gah, what the hell?!
NOO!
*Pewds starts screaming for the man's safety*
*Metal music continues playing*
If this is fake, then he's doing a great job, but I really- OH MY GOD, Jesus!!! It has to be fake...
That's impressive though...
D*mn I'd be sh*ttin myself if I saw that
Hello, my followers. I'm here with legendary comedian movie star uh, Bill Murray.
You know him from such films as the Ghostbusters and the Ghostbusters 2- that's right these
Anderson films and we're just gonna make one of my biggest dreams come true. So ready bill. Yes really ready live from New York it's Saturd- F*CK.
What the Hell did I just watch
You laugh you're confused is so far all I got, Jesus Christ
What is this? Can someone explain why Bill Murray is there and did Bill Murray just hit that guy in the neck?
Song: You mad cause you got some fat breast (Fat Breast)
Song: Yeah he has some fat breast
It's your boy Whis. I just got some neck
Alright, okay, cool
*weeb noise*
Google-San
Back at uh google-san. Oh
My god
Has that dog never seen a car before like. Quit, Jesus Christ dog, please stop stop
Stop please
Dog stop, someone stop the dog
Undefeated dog. dog-
nobody:
my dog: at 5 a.m
*loud barking from Tyler, kinda like AROUHROUHROUH ROUHROUHROUH
See what I'm talking about? I'm sure he's normal. I'm sure there's nothing wrong with him
Hey, it's just me, you know when people take out of context and I-I
I don't want to judge someone's character just by clips taken out of context but uh...
*demon spawn noises that are slowly making me deaf...*
So far it's not looking good
Sh*t
*Minecraft death song*
*BLOMP BA...* (felix why u interupt this beautiful music?)
This.. is so sad, this is why you drink G-Fuel #ad
This won't happen with g-fu- wHAT
*shhh.....*
*BOOOOOM*
What did you think was gonna happen Jesus Christ. It like hey guys, it's me and coca-cola
it's like put the hand over it too like
*BOOOM*
*beew bew*
*bew*
*BUUUUU BUUUU BUUU BUU BUU*
*BUUU BUUU-*
Oh H*ll Yeah
I Love me in a good Yoshi Meme
Oh God
*when you realize the meme is dead like:* Q_Q
What the freak?
Mutters: Oh my god
that just mean
*burps unceremoniously*
That kid? What can he do?                                 Captain Knuckles: Flapjack do that  thing you do every day
I know what this is
Stop, stop the tetris
STOP!
Hey it's another one of these godd*mn memes. We know it's not real, we know - Oh
Oh my god!
oh my GAAAH !
OH, WOW
OH MY GOD , IT'S AMAZING!
IT'S THE MOST BEAUTIFUL THING I'VE
EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE !
AHAH
Nice
Very nice.
Excellent!
OH Jesus Christ , and he locked it as well , Well well done
Hey when we go out make sure you wait like 20 seconds
Jesus
Hey, man, what's wrong?
Come on, you know better lightning mcqueen isn't real. That's true Jeff. Oh gosh guys
Dumbest thing I've ever laughed at but if you laugh you win, so it doesn't matter. Thank you everyone for watching you laugh. You win
Everyone wins today pat yourself on the back
Give yourself an extra
Smoothie shake and I'll see you guys tomorrow on another video leave a like if you laughs and leave a like if you didn't laugh
And make sure to laugh everyone
Ha ha hah ha ha ha HAAAA
Bye!
What ? Tubers Simulators is becoming relevant! (wait this is the old outro..? Brad explain yourself!)
No, no, don't leave
No, please
Sponsor Eagle please do something
Yes
This game is still relevant , god dammit!